a los siete años me enamoré un robot de
algo como esto y me encantó
yo quería poder hacer máquinas construir
estas máquinas para que hicieran cosas
por mí así que le pedí a mis papás que
me metieran a clases de robótica estuve
estudiando allí tres años ya los diez la
realidad es que yo he sido siempre un
mal estudiante
así que mis papás no amenazaron y me
dijeron diego si no subes tus
calificaciones y vamos a sacar de tus
clases de robótica yo estaba muy
asustado porque la boleta llegaba en dos
semanas y sabía que no iba a llegar al
promedio gerente en un intento
desesperado por tratar de continuar
haciendo esto que tanto me gustaba
decidí ir con el director de la academia
dónde estaba estudiando y le pedí
trabajo de maestro
y sorprendentemente hasta la fecha no sé
por qué accedió y medio el trabajo
entonces me convertí en un pequeño
maestro de 10 años dándole clases a
niños y jóvenes de entre 4 y 14 años de
edad llegó el día de la boleta y mis
papás me dicen diego que muy mal te
vamos a tener que sacar de tus clases a
lo que yo les contesté va ya no podré ya
no podré ir a mis clases pero me podrían
llevar a trabajar mañana
así que es la manera que encontré para
continuar haciendo esto que tanto me
gustaba en mis papás no les queda opción
las que seguirme llevando
entonces a los 10 años si nos ponemos a
pensar por qué hice eso ahorita yo
pienso que fue algo muy estúpido es una
idea bastante estúpido niño de 10 años
pidiendo trabajo
pero en ese momento hacía todo el
sentido de mi cabeza en ese momento yo
dije ah pues no hay ningún problema lo
pudiera clases pues las voy a dar porque
yo no sabía los obstáculos que habían
adentro todo lo que estaba en medio que
no tengo la edad no tengo el
conocimiento o ni siquiera tengo la edad
para trabajar entonces otro ejemplo de
eso es que ese mismo año los 10 yo en un
supermercado y vi a lo lejos una persona
en un andador yo no sabía que era o por
qué lo tenía comienza a preguntar y en
ese momento me contestaban que muy
probablemente tiene una discapacidad
motriz es decir no se podía mover bien
lo siguió observando y me di cuenta que
la luz para que para mí es completamente
sencillo cómo agarrar una manzana pero
esta persona era prácticamente imposible
ese día empatiza muchísimo con esta
persona y me hizo una promesa un día voy
a hacer algo para que esta persona
regrese a tener toda la independencia
que hoy no tiene no sabía qué hacer ni
cómo hacerlo tampoco sabía que esa
promesa iba a cambiar mi vida años más
tarde seis años después me di cuenta que
no estaba haciendo nada por esta promesa
decidí poner manos a la obra
y comencé investigar sobre
discapacidades cuánta gente las tenía
qué dificultades tenían y qué
herramientas tenían hoy para solucionar
todas sus necesidades
y descubrí que para la utiliza en
muchísimas cosas y todos los días salen
cosas nuevas pero que hay de todas las
demás discapacidades probablemente
tenían muchos problemas similares ahí
descubrí que cada cinco segundos alguien
pierde la vista
y metas otras industrias han
evolucionado muchísimo como la de los
carros o la de los celulares el bastón
para personas ciegas no ha cambiado
absolutamente nada y en un mundo tan
cambiante como el nuestro esta
herramienta dejó de ser precisa se
convierte en una herramienta es
actualizada y con muchísimas limitantes
yo sabía que hay tiene que ser algo
porque como puede ser que tantas
personas estén utilizando esta
herramienta tan obsoleta si hay más de
300 millones de personas con
discapacidad visual en el mundo
comenzamos a trabajar en un dispositivo
porque que mejor de combinar lo que más
me gusta con esta promesa que yo había
hecho así que tenía que tener robótica
esto empezamos a trabajar en este
dispositivo no sabíamos muy bien a dónde
íbamos así que comenzamos a conocer
gente con discapacidad visual a ver qué
necesitaban qué opinaban y qué pensaban
de lo que estábamos haciendo ya con un
pequeño avance ahí conocí a rafa rafael
un atleta paralímpico que corría 400 y
1500 metros planos a los 22 años
rafa perdió la vista y se vio forzado
por esta discapacidad a dejar de hacer
lo que más le gustaba que era correr ese
día rafa me dijo que con esto que
estábamos haciendo el día puede regresar
a correr y después regresar a hacer lo
que más lo que más le gustaba otro caso
como es el de víctor víctor yo iba en
una feria en un evento y me lo topé voy
viendo un al señor con un bastón de
ciegos en la mano no dude en acercarme
le conté lo que estábamos haciendo y
rápidamente aceptó en probarse el
dispositivo que estábamos creando y
víctor se empezó a mover en un evento de
más de 15.000 personas como si nada sin
guía sin bastón sin instrucciones con
una sonrisa de oreja a oreja
después le hizo una pequeña entrevista a
victoria y le dije víctor en una palabra
cómo te sientes cómo te sentiste con
este dispositivo a lo que él me contestó
normal como si pudiera volver a ver
en este momento mi propósito y mis ganas
por trabajar en esto fueron muchísimo
más grandes y con muchísima más fuerza
comenzamos a trabajar más todavía pero
llegó un momento donde mis conocimientos
ya no eran suficientes necesitaba gente
que supiera más y fuera más especialista
en el tema
en ese momento logré contratar a una
persona para que diseñar un circuito
nuevo para el dispositivo que estábamos
haciendo que lo logramos pagar por medio
de un premio que ganamos unas semanas
antes seguimos trabajando muchísimo y
pronto me comenzaron a llegar llamadas y
correos de personas que querían
comprarlo se veían enterado de lo que
estábamos haciendo y yo nunca pensé que
esto puede llegar a ser un producto yo
pensaba esto como un proyecto pero en
ese momento me di cuenta que esto dejó
de ser un proyecto más y pasó a ser un
emprendimiento social que hoy está
revolucionando como las personas ciegas
exploran el mundo
desarrollamos el primer sustituto al
bastón para personas ciegas este es un
dispositivo que se pone en el pecho como
una prenda y detecta cualquier tipo de
obstáculo le avisa al usuario por medio
de vibraciones cuando va a chocar con
algún objeto dependiendo de la
intensidad de la vibración y dependiendo
de la posición quiere decir qué tipo de
obstáculo tienes en tu camino después de
meses de trabajo logramos detectar cosas
en la cabeza cosas en el pecho como
personas paredes y ventanas y cosas en
la parte baja como escenarios baches
bordes y escaleras una real innovación
en esto que estábamos haciendo
y seguimos trabajando
pronto esto comenzó a ser más y más
grande cada vez
y bueno
hoy vemos es trap como este dispositivo
como la siguiente herramienta estándar
aspiramos a que ya no se asocie un
bastón con una persona ciega sino que se
asocia nuestro dispositivo con una
persona ciega y cada vez darles más
independencia que se puedan mover con
mucha más seguridad y con mucha más
autonomía que no necesitan ayuda de
nadie más para hacer sus actividades
quieran no tengan que pedir ayuda como
es el caso de javier javier es un ex
ejecutivo que perdió la vista por
sobrecarga de trabajo hoy javier hace
ciclismo tenis y golf
y también lo invitan a dar muchas
conferencias
entonces javier me pidió que se podía
utilizar este dispositivo para dar sus
conferencias porque tenía el bastón en
la mano tenerlo que estar usando una
mano ocupada era bastante complicado con
este dispositivo a javier la vista
cuando va a llegar a la orilla del
escenario donde están las entradas y
dónde están el atril óseo el monitor
entonces queremos hacer esto con más
personas cada vez demostrar que tener
una discapacidad no es un obstáculo sino
todo lo contrario es una prueba para
demostrarle al mundo que no por ser una
persona ciega no puedes realizar sus
actividades y moverte
y me gustaría recordar por qué estoy
aquí hoy estoy aquí parado con todos
ustedes y todo por tomar una decisión
estúpida de pedirle trabajo los 10 años
a un señor
entonces estás tan pequeño y no conoces
no sabes existen todo tipo de obstáculos
cuando eres más grande ya conoces lo que
hay en medio y dices no hagas no lo voy
a hacer porque hay esto ahí estoy hay
extra a los 10 años no tienes
conocimiento de lo que te vas a
enfrentar y al mismo tiempo tienes una
motivación y una energía gigantesca para
mí la combinación perfecta
entonces si ver el mundo de esta manera
ha hecho llegar no solamente a mí sino a
muchas personas muy lejos si tienes esta
combinación perfecta pero vas a
descubrir obstáculos pero si tu
propósito es lo suficientemente fuerte
como para ganarle estos obstáculos no
vas a tener ningún problema entonces yo
les quiero preguntar por qué no vemos el
mundo como un niño de 10 años gracias
[Aplausos]